le chef de police à toronto
le shérif de flint au michigan
le premier ministre à ottawa
les images largement diffusées pendant
les manifestations contre le racisme et
la brutalité policière
si elles sont vues comme une main tendue
par certains pour d'autres c'est le
contraire tant que ce soit en quête de
justice ce genre de geste là est très
prématuré pour émilie nicolas c'est tout
simplement trop tôt trop douloureux ça
pourrait ouvrir beaucoup de blessures
remettent le fer dans la plaie des
personnes ici même à montréal par
exemple qui ont perdu un être cher aux
mains de la police qui ont jamais une
justice monsieur de demain avec les gens
la demande des organisateurs
après avoir accepté de participer à la
marche contre la brutalité policière
prévue dimanche le chef du spvm s'est vu
retirer son invitation par les
organisateurs on a annoncé l'invitation
de la police et maintenant le focus est
devenue la police afin de pourquoi on
est en train de marcher ensemble et b et
ce synode note notre souci majeur le
souci de ne pas perdre l'objectif de la
manifestation dénoncer le racisme le
profilage et la brutalité policière
les gens ont besoin de concret ali
nestor n'est pas contre la présence des
dirigeants mais il veut plus que du
spectacle il faut que les gestes suivent
j'aurais l'impression qu'ils ont tout
simplement riz de nous alors ils sont
venus ils ont fait belle figure des
belles photos ils ont mis un genou à
terre mais par la suite nous ont rien
fait alors là moi j'aurais l'impression
d'avoir fait rire de moi que je pense
que c'est un peu le même genre de
réflexe que les gens ont de faire comme
goethe attenberg de ne pas être
impressionné parce que le chef de police
de la ville de montréal
ce n'est pas un citoyen d'inès une
poussée de la personne qui est peut-être
le plus de pouvoir de faire changer les
choses parce qu'en cette période
sensible
chaque geste même empreint de bonne
volonté et paisible sont la balance
douleurs du passé
si jacques andré charbonneau reds au
canada morere
[Musique]